and now name of the opening everybody
should know in this room the name of the
opening Slav defense okay and we play
which move all right guys welcome to a
more advanced class and we're gonna talk
about this opening called Slav defense
today and I'm gonna be showing you how
to play against the Slav defense and get
an advantage okay it that way if anybody
plays the Slav then you have a chance to
get an advantage that's my specialty
okay since I've been a default player
for close to thirty years now
okay so d4 d5 c4 c6 and which opening we
have everybody Slav defense okay
so it's a very solid defense not easy to
get advantage against but you're gonna
try to get the advantage against it and
the line that I want to recommend to you
is you take on d5 you take on d5 and you
play the exchange variation against the
Slav okay so this is for you to play
here as white d4 okay now he takes
Knight f3 Knight f6
93 96
so we have the Slav and now do we want
to play three here or we want to play
something before we play three here
which would you would like to play
before you play the movie three here
yes addict Bishop f4 yes
developing the bishop excellent now
black has several moves here one is a
6-1 it's is six one is Bishop f5 so
these are all playable moves so I'm
going to show you all of them okay so
first if he plays III slightly passive
and can you tell me what's the what's
wrong with this move like it's why is it
slightly pass it what is this move doing
yes excellent it's blocking it's
blocking the bishop okay excellent
yes that's the problem of this move with
this move but it keeps it solid i've had
i had some strong grandmaster play this
against me okay so III now he plays
Bishop d6 offering you the exchange of
the bishops what do you think white
should play here
what should we play here you Bishop g3
human Bishop letter number okay peace
letter number okay Bishop g3 excellent
now if he takes you word is the rule
what is the rule that we capture wave
here most of the time I would say at
least 90% of the time we capture how we
capture which way we capture yes with
the pond where which way we have two
ways to capture right which way you
capture from the side towards the center
or from the center towards the side yes
h-town takes from the side towards the
center and you have the the file as well
here okay
from the side towards the center okay
now he castles now what do you do now
you want to try together you want to try
to get a development here which piece
you can try to develop yes excellent yes
Phillip Bishop d3 activating the bishop
and putting pressure putting pressure
okay
now he plays b6
now this b6 is already losing move this
b6 is already losing move why
why is b6 losing movie doesn't look like
you should be losing here yes
Bishop b5 but that's more like attacking
right I will probably just go Bishop e7
something more active I want see from
you something more active here
Michael but he plays g6 or h6 you know
Quincy to be plays g6 or h6
so something active can you close the
door please
hmm all right come come take a seat here
in the front here right here or right
there here you have to make an active
move yes B or e this is b5 but then I
play a six and I'm kind of attacking you
usually want to put the Knights in the
center your Knights your Knights belong
in a center okay your Knights belong in
the center yes ah D G in the center he
five yes 95 I just play h-60 95
excellent attacking the knight now he
defends and now a tactic a strong tactic
you can do here tactic time to win the
game here with a tactical combination
okay how
what is the tactical combination to win
here yes miss pay six I take back fish
pay six I take 26
yes
King h8
now he cannot take because if he takes
the problem is you go Queen h5 and you
have pressure he moves here checkmate
so that's why he goes here King h8 now
the idea is very very nice here you're
not gonna made here but you're gonna be
able to win the Queen here it's a nice
combination it's a nice combination
couple of moves you have to calculate to
win the Queen nice combination to win
the Queen
let's think for a couple of minutes
before we let's think for a few minutes
before we say the most because it's not
so easy lots of ideas
okay yes
correct now correct nice very nice very
good combination what is your rating
nice very strong
who else see that idea you were thinking
about that guys
Michael the idea here using the idea
that basically the King on h8 is
overworked it's doing too many things
it's overworked ok so that's why you
have to use this idea to break through
so that's why you will start out with
Bishop f7 takes check has to take like
f7 mates ok
now if it goes to g8 we just take the
clintus to go here okay alright let's
review this opening and see if you're
gonna remember that all of this moves go
ahead start with the first one first of
all wait who has it raise your hands yes
okay second move wait wait
and now name of the opening everybody
should know in this room the name of the
opening Slav defense okay and we play
which move and you should know the name
of this variation what is the name of
this variation Adi exchange variation
because you're exchanging okay that
could exchange variation okay here go
ahead yes okay yes
you six
and now he locked his bishop that's not
the best yeah so now what can you do yes
huh no not yet not yet
III first right now he wants to take
your bishop
he wants to take the bishop now what can
you do here
now what is the idea to play here yes
him nice
he takes how do we capture here yes na h
bond from the side towards the center ok
one side towards the center castle now
which piece you want to develop now we
need to have the pieces developed here
yes
night which one we play first which
piece we develop first so we have an
attack yeah
p6
yes better better
now you gotta activate your night where
yes yes night belongs in the center
right now goes here
and this is the moment to break
the moment to break
yes
Bravo
if it takes
now the Queen comes in right queen h5
it's made if it was made by the way if
it goes here how do you checkmate in two
moves how do you checkmate in two moves
it
yes
nice
checkmate
so he goes King h8 because of that and
then what do you do yes now you have the
idea here to win idea to win here yes
okay but how check he goes here continue
yes takes
to X takes perfect
when you have Czech winning the Queen
and winning the game okay
all right so that's one is good let's
take a look at another line here a very
very interesting life if they play here
Bishop a5 now you play you play III here
now he plays is six and I want to
recommend to you to play the move Queen
to b3
attacking on b7 and now black has
several moves here but a lot of the
moves black plays here actually losing
the game so for example rook b8 just
drops the rook exchange if he plays b6
it's very bad because it's losing
because of which move there should be 5
pinning and then attacking and you
cannot do anything Queen d7 is losing
because of donors
yes tics don't rush
95 is good but if you take what the
bishop here then I can play a six yeah I
just play a six so what can you do first
better look at their pawn on d4 what can
you do
yes
tick tick with the pawn now the knight
is on their attack most likely your
opponent will go here most likely your
opponent will go there and if he goes
there
what is the winning move most likely
will go there and what is the winning
move here you absolutely Bishop b5 very
nice Bishop comes in here and wins the
game okay so so when you play Queen b3
there is another move he can play 95
that looks kind of okay you know but
it's also losing Bishop if I check now
he plays Knight d7
now you play Queen a for putting
pressure putting pressure okay
now if it goes back yeah now you're
talking to take and win it like if you
place a six sec and it take okay
[Music]
so the only move the best move is here
Bishop before for him then rook c1 and
your queen is gonna be if you play rook
c8 then just simply rook c1 and you're
gonna feel comfortable here the queen
okay so has to play Bishop before
there should be five the idea is to take
take on before okay now he castles
yes what is your question here yeah a
couple is but this is considered
slightly worse take a three Roxie one
this is just slightly worse because of
the doubled pawns okay double pants are
not good they considered bad okay so
there should be five threatening to take
on before now black castles usually by
the way if you're thinking about Queen
b6 move which was played against me once
with the idea that if you take on c6 he
takes back with a punch okay but the
problem here is
if we do that white has this is a
blunder Queen b6 because white has a
move here that wins the piece which move
is it that wins the piece
yes
better no you can just take what can you
take here yes better a little bit better
can you take the bishop you can right
you just take the bishop and now he
cannot take back because you have a pin
okay
yeah because if he takes it he cannot
take because of the pin so very
important idea okay
he castles you take he takes he has to
take because otherwise if he takes back
here you're just winning the bishop so
check and now you have a choice here
you can take the pawn on c6 or you can
cancel what do you thing is the best
idea so what's the idea what's the idea
here
yes
do you want to take the pawn or castle
yes you want to cancel because safety of
the king is very important okay so
remember to castle first okay before you
start grabbing some pants safety of the
King is very important
so castle sorry now he plays let's say
here Brooke FC one putting pressure on
the knight pawn rook c8 and you just
activate the knight and white is
slightly better here because black has a
weak pawn on c6 and you cannot place if
I because I take so that's so that's a
problem here okay alright and White has
a nice position so let's review this to
make sure you guys remember okay alright
go ahead first humans you know what to
do so Slav so we come to the new move
Bishop f5 now what do we play against
this move Phillip what do you do first
III is six and then going to be three
attacking so a lot of moves are losing
and the best move is Bishop before
so again b6 is losing to Bishop e5 Queen
d7 losing to 9595 losing to Bishop b5
here
Quincy it is just bad luck c1 rook b8
just drops the rook so Queen b6 is just
slightly worse because of the backwards
double pounds so the best move is Bishop
before so then you go be sure before
threatening to take the bishop Queen b6
loses to cap it loses to capture and you
cannot take back because of the pin so
has to play
Castle take take the bishop
takes
now do you want to take the pawn no
castle before you grab palms make sure
your king is canceled safety of the king
is very important okay so make sure you
get your safety first before you grab
the pawns okay he goes here now
see you on putting pressure and now
ninety five putting some more pressure
okay
putting some more pressure on c6 and
White has a nice advantage here okay got
it okay good all right let's do one
tactic before we start playing the
practice games okay so in this tactic
you're playing with the white pieces you
have to play like a first world champion
who knows the name of the first world
champion sure if you were here in the
previous class you know that okay who is
the first world champion Michael William
Steinitz
William Stein needs became a world
champion which year 1886
to 1894 remember that record yeah 1886
to 1894 William stannis was the first
unofficial champion and before him who
was the unofficial world champion I told
you he was by many considered
unofficially first world champion and
Aries Adi yes
Paul Morphy all right so in this
position you have to play like steinitz
and find a mate how how are you going to
do it
how you're going to do it 1 2 3 4 5 but
it's pretty forcing it's pretty forcing
first move then he takes me the rock
route takes me seven he takes back with
the rook better
Quinn GA Michael that is sacrificing a
queen
slow down Shula one more at the time to
King c7 right has to go checkmate
you're not going ever taken taken so
let's do the idea again so we start out
with the Queen sacrifice Queen sacrifice
checks
he has to take check he goes here check
he goes here
da check mate thanks to that very strong
bishop on d5 okay thanks to that very
strong Bishop on d5 you're gonna be able
to checkmate here okay and that's how
first world champion William Steinitz
made it his opponent okay you got to
look for this kind of ideas okay if you
see that direct ideas don't work you
have to start looking for sacrifices
captures okay you have to look for this
opportunities okay all right guys
excellent job
[Music]